Hey how it's going bro's STREIGHTEGTEH
my name is Pewdiepie
So I made a tweet saying that
"I'm gonna release season two of Scare Pewdiepie, if it gets a hundred thousand retweets"
Cause as some of you know,
scare Pewdiepie the show that I worked on
Scare Pewdiepie, the show that I worked on
for about a month, got cancelled.
for about a month
Got cancelled
Because "I'm a Nazi"
because, I'm a Nazi
But the show is still there, the show is still out there
it's ready to go
and I'm just sitting on it, i-i'm not supposed to obviously but
it feels right, it feels
it feels needed because so many people worked on it and it just seems fair that instead of youtube just cancelling it and throwing away the show
you guys can at least watch and enjoy it, so
I know im probably gunna get in trouble for this but I-I think
it's-it's-it seems fair to do and I really I really really hope that you guys are gunna enjoy it
so without further ado
I can't believe i'm saying this, please enjoy episode one of Scare Pewdiepie, Season two
*Dramatic Music build up*
*INTRO*
*Silence*
Huagh
Arghhh
Ahhhh
*Slightly Louder* Ahhhhhhhh
*Still louder* Ahhhh
*Voice Crack* Ahhhhh
*Really Bad Jingle*
*Silence*
Huagh
*Almost Orgasmic* Ahhhhh
*Out of breath* Ahh
ugh hwugh
You scared me, what the hell man?
It's a Prank!
It's a prank bro!
You got pranked!
Is this scare Pewdiepie season two?
Scare Pewdiepie Season two Episode one
I wasn't ready, you didn't tell me
Episode one
Oh my god
*Silence with a hint of leaves rustling*
Huagh
*RIP Headphone users* Ahhhhhhhhhh
*Box's and other noises*
It was for the show
What the fuck man?
Scare Pewdiepie Season two!
*Fairly Sexual* Ughhh
Oh it's a good show, this season's got me in it Jacksepticeye.
*High pitched voice* Ahh top of the mornin' *Fwa pshh*
and I'm going to be scaring Pewdiepie myself this time are ya ready? Let's go!
*More box sounds*
*Near silence with a hint of water*
*Noise*
*Loud* Augh!
Oh-ho, Jack I don't know what to do
Okay we've been filming this video
and he's like
and he's like "Super Scared" but now I'm really gunna scare him
*Camera Noises*
Hey Felix
Yeah?
YouTube have uh, de-monetised the whole channel
How do you know?
I just checked
the ad sense is unlinked
Woah, woah, woah, woah
*Bang*
*Sound of metal hitting metal*
It's just a prank bro
he he he he he hay
*Shitty Jingle again*
That was the joke
*Wheezing*
Yeah, no obviously
I can't, I can't leak the show. It-It is a shame
the fact that it's all done
it's all filmed, it's all ready
it's just sitting there.
and now I think
that it's been like a couple weeks since
I became a Nazi
Lookin' at it now
wh-when the dust has settled it's like whyyy why is this happened? It just seems so stupid
Uh, especially the fact that other people who worked on, cause so many people worked on the show
their work doesn't get to be out there because of some stupid fucking jokes like
it seems
almost insane, uhm, and it's a shame it's a damn shame
uh Jack was a huge part of the show he was gunna be like the villain of the show
and he had a big involvement and it was a lot of fun going on between me and to, we had a guest in every single episode so 10-10 other YouTube'rs and
and personalities were guest's. Ethan and Hila from H3 who are Jewish by the way *Laughing* It's like
You fucked, you fucked Jewish people over by cancelling the show like Good Job, Good Job you did it
Ken was going to be on the show obviously, Mark ate, Mark ate uh Pig Testicles
Ehmmmm
Which you will never see the light of day
Ken, CinnamonToastKen got dipped in shit For NOTHING
There's just so much shit that we did that month and it's
Arghh
I hate it, I hate it, but
This is how it is
Shit happens
Uhhhh, what are you gunna do?
A looki-Looking back as well when we filmed that show
it was literally the worst month
I-I Actually I don't wanna be over dramatic but it seems like-it was definitely one of the worst months I ever experienced filming that show
Not because I didn't enjoy filming the show I had such a blast it was such an amazing and fun thing to do, I upload videos every single day
and for me to
do that and film a show at the same time was a fucking nightmare, it was the worst idea I've ever had to think that I could do that
then when I realised I couldn't do that
along with all these other things happening as well at the same time I was fucking depressed like it was driving me crazy
I-You saw the video i'm fucking crying like a little baby
I-I-It's so stupid
I just need to finish what I'm doing here in L.A
I need to put myself first, so disappointed
!!!DISAPPOINTED!!!
at least I don't have to do season 3 *Bad Umm Tss*
Oh yeah, I hope you're not mad at me for lying to you, i'm sorry /s
I think if there is one thing out of all-all these things happening that I would like to see changed, It is the fact that the show should come out I really really think it should
and hopefully in the future you'll be able to watch it, but until then you'll just have another shitty YouTube video, you're welcome